[Musik]
einige formel 1 freunde ein spannendes
rennen war das nicht heute in frankreich
der sieg von lewis hamilton sein 79
davon wirklich von der ersten sekunde
bis zur letzten absolut ungefährdet hat
seinen teamkollegen valtteri bottas im
identischen autos zwei kleinere
technische probleme hat aber doch sehr
deutlich vor allen dingen von dem anfang
des rennens distanziert er hat ferrari
clark auf rang drei stark distanziert so
dass man sagen muss ferrari trotz der
runderneuerung trotz neuer teile keine
chance das war kein schritt zur wende im
kampf um die wm
ich würde sagen sogar er ein kleiner
rückschritt vettel kam von sieben auf
fünf vor
immerhin das an zwei mclaren vorbei aber
dann nicht weiter doch er ist sozusagen
der punktsieger des tages weil er die
schnellste rennrunde gefahren ist aber
doch diese kleine geschichte
verdeutlicht eigentlich sehr klar welche
probleme ferrari hat und wie groß der
unterschied zu mercedes ist vettel fuhr
um 24 tausendstelsekunden also meine
jungs schneller als hamilton
in der allerletzten runde aber eben auch
ganz neuen reifen während hamilton ganz
alte vor grösser und ja eigentlich
deutlicher kann man diesen unterschied
nicht illustrieren was bedeutet das
jetzt acht rennen hat mercedes gewonnen
sechs davon allein hamilton acht von
acht rennen also in der tasche der
silberpfeile und jetzt werden schon
sozusagen erste vorwürfe an den sieger
laut ich halte das für ein bisschen
merkwürdig dass man im spitzensport
jemanden der erfolg hat diesen auch
vorwirft ich denke man muss es umdrehen
man muss sich die frage stellen warum
denn die gegner bei gleicher ausstattung
die
ressourcen sind ja zum teil nicht
schlechter die fahrer auch nicht sie
eben nicht schaffen da auf augenhöhe zu
kommen
mag sein dass das mit den reifen
zusammenhängt dass die reifen von
pirelli besser passen zum mercedes aber
diese reifen wurden vorgeführt nach dem
letzten rennen in abu dhabi im
vergangenen jahr und jeder konnte sie
auch testen im winter und soweit ich
mich erinnere gab es damals kleine klage
jetzt kommen sie ob man sie jetzt
während der saison noch ändern sollte
ich meine nicht so sind die regeln
daran muss man sich halten und man muss
eben mercedes auch einmal sagen guten
job gemacht und wenn es dann nun eben
aus der sicht frühere formel 1 fans
nicht so spannend ist dann ist es halt
so und dann ist es eigentlich ein
zeichen nur dass mercedes so starkes und
die anderen vielleicht einfach zu
schwach leider ist auch innerhalb des
teams nicht so wie man sich das wünscht
als jemand der ein spannendes formel 1
rennen sehen will zumindest hier in
frankreich hat des futters wieder nicht
geschafft auf augenhöhe zu fahren und
hätten erst im qualifying 03 sekunden
auf die schnellste runde zurück und auch
im rennen am anfang nicht auf der höhe
dann wisst an ziert und selbst wenn es
seien kleinere technische probleme
gegeben haben sollte wie das team und
auch der fahrer sagen so passiert es
doch nicht dass hamilton bin jetzt
wieder fest im griff hat mit 36 punkte
führt hamilton nun von waters mit 77 gar
vor sebastian vettel der auf rang drei
der fahrerwertung liegt und das sagt
eben nun schon wirklich dass das
möglicherweise mit dem wm titel für
vettel in diesem jahr nichts mehr wird
davon muss man ausgehen wenn ich ein
wunder geschieht aber die sind in der
formel eins äußerst selten bleibt zum
abschied noch von diesem grand prix das
letzte wort von hamilton
am kommenden sonntag findet das wenn in
österreich statt und das wird sicherlich
nicht so einfach wie dieses hier in
frankreich sagt er wieder ein schweres
aber so sind sie die siegertypen thema
zweifeln und dann beim nächsten einen
doch gewinnen
das fahrzeug
[Musik]